それで幸福になるためにどうすればよろしいかと
まず誓願ですね というか
決めることです 失敗しない
不幸にならない 成功する
結果を出すということをまず決めておくんです
私は失敗しないことにするぞと
結果は出すぞと 成功するぞと
それが必要ですよ という心は弱くて
感情に振り回される  １秒の 100分の1でも気持ちは変わるんです
だから決めておかないと全然耐えれないんですよ
心は  1分 1秒の 100分の1でも気持ち変わったんです
だから誓願は必要なんです
優柔不断では何もできん
次に その結果を出すために必要な原因
能力 努力などを探し出す
それで決めて覚悟を決めてから
じゃあこの結果出すためにどうすればよろしいかと
ちゃんと調べなくちゃいけない
自分でわからないんだったら教えてもらうんです
今の自分にその原因は揃ってないことも明確に理解しておく
例えばあの課長になってやろうと思ったら
課長になる原因 今ないんですよ
だから平の社員ですよ
原因そこまでは揃ってますよ
だから普通の社員が課長になるそうと思ったら
自分にその原因は今ないんです
その能力も実績も何もないんです
だからこの それをよく理解しておかないと
だからいろいろ勉強して
どうなれば どういう条件揃ったら課長になれるのかと
それはスタディをしなくちゃいけないんです
勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
いろんな人から聞いてもらわなくちゃいけない
次にやることは理解ですね
理解は前も出ましたけど
結果を妨げる原因を探し出す
で あのタイトルちょこっとずれてます
あの理解は前のスライドにも 1行ありました
で それから原因があっても
例えばこれぐらい実績があって
これぐらいのことを勉強して
これぐらいのことを知識あれば課長ぐらいになれるぞとかあっても
これ妨げるものもありますよ
妨げることを勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
それはほとんど今の自分の中に存在しているんですよ
結果出せない原因は今自分持ってるんです
良い結果出す原因は自分持ってないんです
だからそういう勉強は必要なんです
実践する過程で現れるものもあります
それから実践すると現れるものもあります
例えば私は瞑想を教える場合は
あの妄想をやめてください
そんなこと言ったって
もう私はもう人間に妄想してる
そんなのわかってますけど
育てにくいんですよ その場合は
人は妄想するのは当たり前で
だからダメになっていて
幸福になりたければ妄想をやめてくださいと
やめる方法はこういう方法やと教えているんだったら
文句言わずにやるしかないでしょうに
妄想はあんまりも出てくると瞑想をやめてもよろしいでしょうかと
妄想は出ない時 瞑想すればよろしい
質問ばっかしで もうもう返事出す気にもならないんですね
もう負け犬でも最初からもう決まってるんです
だから心の中で負け犬になりそうと決まってるんだから
それは私たちには見えますよ
本人に見えなくても だから全然こちらも期待しない態度で
もうすごい失礼な返事出すんです
別に怒ったっても知るもんかと
どうせもう失敗作やと
どうせ負け犬やと だから瞑想中も妄想が出てどうしようもないんだけど
あの まあなんとかあの
どうしましょうかと聞けば
あの なんとかないんでしょうか
これと聞けば その人やりたい気持ちでしょうし
その時やめればやめてもよろしいでしょうかとかね
あるいは私は真言密教に馴染みがあるんだから
呪文唱えたらよろしいでしょうかとかね
勝手にやれば そこで 一旦実行に移しても
またボロが出ますよ 自分今までなかったものでも
例えば自分がすごいしっかり者だと思ったところで
瞑想を始めたらどことなまけが出てくるとかね
それはありますよ それもチェックしなくちゃいけないんです
隠れていたもの 知識人に
経験者に聞いて学んだ方が無難です
だからとにかく知識人に
経験者に聞くんです それしか人間に道がないんですよ
知識人 経験者っていうのは目上と縦の関係なんです
だからお釈迦様は言うんですよ
仏教はもう縦の関係で
専修としか専有と違よると悟れますよと
専有は誰やというと私ですよというのは
私ではなくてお釈迦様です
お釈迦様は神様仏ではないんです
生命の専有であると指導者であると
最後に実行ですね それは YMT ということで
期待する結果を出す原因が揃うようにと実行実践するんです
期待通りに物事は変わっていくことは実感できます
原因だけ変わっていけば
何のことなく結果が出ているんですよ
あの病気になった時と同じなんですよ
医者は病気を治すことはしないでしょうに
原因を何とかするんです
病気治ることっていうのは自動的なんです
原因がなかったらもう病気でもないんです
しかし 期待は悪なら実る
実る以前 こういう変な変になっています
自己破壊になります  こうなりそうと思ったことは
自分は目的を作るでしょう
その目的が悪の目的だったら
達する前に自己破壊になるんです
成功はしない 途中でやられます
例えば強盗して 1億円貯まってやれそうと思ったら
1000万のところでもう逮捕されます
あるいは殺されます 期待は善なら期待を上回って成功する
自分がした目的が良い目的だったら
期待を外れてものすごく上回るんですよ
まあわかるでしょ 例えばマザーテレサがやることないんだから
そこら辺にいる貧しい人々をなんとか水でもあげましょうというぐらいの程度で始めた作業なんですよ
まあいいじゃない 国に回されたんだと
まあしょうがない 道路で住んでいる人々
死にかけている人々にちょこっと助けてあげましょうと
そこで人を助けようという清らかな思考なんですよ
善的な目的ですよ 結果どうでしょうかと
本人にも想像できない結果になっちゃったんです
上回るんですよ マザーテレサの話の中でも
そこまでは自分は考えていなかったと
何でも期待ではなく 善を期待しましょう
だから我々はなんでも期待するんじゃなくて
善 良いものだけ 欲望でいいんです
良いものに欲望する 良いものを願望する
良い善なるものを希望する
それでいいんです 欲望が悪いということでもないんです
欲望だったら悪いんだけど
まあ良いものに期待かけることがいいんです
上回って成功する はい
次に行きます 次のポイント
この今の瞬間ということ
過去もありますけど 未来もありますけど
大事なのは今の瞬間ということ
大事なのは実際しない
過去でも未来でもありません
実際しないんだからいない
ないんだから それを考えると現実離れになる
エネルギーは浪費する
現在お金はなくてはならないことができなくなる
時間っていうのは流れるんであって
ストップしないでしょうに
同じ時間は二度と来ないんですね
機会はいつでも一回きりなんです
一期一会っていうことだからね
この一回きりのチャンス逃しちゃうと
もうどうにもならん それがなんで逃がすのかというと
過去のことが将来のことか妄想するんだから
行為に結果が現れる 行為は今ここで行うものなのです
行為に結果が現れるんだから
行為っていうのは今やるものなんです
だから今やるべきことをやれば
他心配することはゼロなんです
結果は現れますよ 勝手に
何のことなく だから 過去現在未来の場合は
今の瞬間ということに徹して生きていなくちゃいけないんです
将来に過去に足を引っ張られる人々は誰でも失敗する
自分がもう達するところ
達するべきところのもうものすごい低い位置にいるんですよ
本当のところ 人間にはそんなもんじゃない
いろんなことできるはずなんですけど
そういうことで やっぱり善悪の分別っていうのは大事ですね
善悪はどうやって分別してますかね
わからないでしょ？何が善で何が悪かと
ブッダの悟りの智慧によって説かれた善悪を理解しておきましょう
世間の話はどうでもいいんです
善悪の場合は 断言的にブッダの話だけ聞いてください
ブッダがこれが善でこれで悪とおっしゃっているならば
それにはもう二言二言はありません
もうこれ断言的にそれは言えます
世の中のことはあまり気にしなくてもいいんです
理由もあります 人のアドバイスというのは曖昧です
例えば聖書でも殺すなかれとあるんだけど
あれって曖昧なんですよ
自分が人を殺しながら殺すなかれと言うんだから
神が なぜ殺すなかれと言ってないんです
俺が言ったんだからやるな
それだけの話でしょうに
だから人のアドバイスというのは曖昧です
他人のことを純粋に心配しない
誰も他人のことというのは心配しないんですよ
自分のことが何よりも大事です
本当に自分のことを心配する人
親のようにのアドバイスは良いが
そちらにも完全な知恵がないことにも要注意
人のアドバイスを聞くならば
相手が私のことを本気で真面目に心配しているのかということなんですよ
みんなそう心配してないんですよ
しかし 親なら子供のことは本気で真面目に心配する
いいいい先生なら 心優しい会社の社長なら
真剣真面目に心配する可能性ありますよ
その場合は その人々のアドバイスは聞いた方がいいんですが
問題があります みんな別に完全に知恵があるわけじゃないんです
自分知ってる範囲で言ってるだけだから
気をつけたいっていうか
注意した方がいいんです
親いうことは 親は完璧に心配してますよ
子供のこと 裏表なし 子供のことを心配してかわいい
成功して幸福になってほしいと
でも 親にしたっても 道を教える自信はないんですよ
自分もあんまりわからないんだからね
そこら辺も理解してほしいんですね
だから無難なのはブッダの話を聞けば
ブッダは完全な慈悲の完成者でしょうに
微妙にでも期待していないんで
人身返りは人々から自分が悟ってるんだから何もいりません
なのに寝る時間も惜しんで教えていたんです
時々食べるものもない
托鉢に出たっても悪口言われちゃって
そうするとお釈迦様は受け取れません
ご飯は断る それでも説法だけはする
だからブッダの話を聞くしかないんだ
これは完全に無なんです
だからブッダに帰依するんです
頼りはブッダしかいないんです
じゃあ早く終わりにしましょう
心はもともと無知無明なので
悪には慣れている 悪いことに慣れてますよ
理解もできる 悪いことだったらすぐ理解する
やりたくもなる 自然に行う
不幸になることだったら自然に行う
しかし 悪果は嫌ですね
いい加減で有り得ない期待ですよ
例えば 勉強するよりは遊ぶことは好きでしょうし
仕事をするよりはふざけることは好きでしょうし
悪いことなら進んで好きなんですけど
しかし 結果嫌や結果嫌やと言ったって結果が出ますよ
善後 心は拒否する傾向です
なんか文法的にはおかしいんですけどね
まあ善ということなら
心はいつでも拒否する傾向です
例えば嘘を言うなと言っちゃうと
そんなこと言われたっても
殺生するなと言ったっても
害虫どうするんでしょうかと
敵はどうするんでしょうかとか
どうしても拒否するんですよ
善を行うために誓願と精進が必須です
だから軽々と良いことできると思ったら
これ勘違い かなり覚悟して頑張らないと
だから誓願ないと たった嘘をつかないってことでも守れませんよ
心は嘘をつくのを好きなんです
殺生することは好きなんです
しかし 悪行為だから悪結果になりますけど
結果だけに文句を言うんです
これはありえない無知な話で
だから覚悟して誓願して決めて挑戦しないと
善行為はない だから幸福もない
それでなくては それで話は一応終わり
それからブッダの言葉をいくつか紹介して終了します
パンダナンチャパランチッタンドゥラックカンドンニワーリャンウジュンカロティメーダービウスカローテジャナン
全部法句経から出しました
皆様 正しい日本訳を調べてください
あの心は揺れる ざわめく
ざわめくというのは私はあまり好きじゃないんですけど
このチャパランというのは
もう当てにならない いい加減で
もうもうグニャグニャというね
今言ったことをすぐもう変えるというね
意味なんです だからざわめくでもないんです
えっ？はっきりしない
当てにならない すぐ 変わってしまう
一定しない で 守り難い
制御しが制御しがたい
智慧のある人はそれをまっすぐにする
正すんです 心はもうどうにもならん
もう生命っていうのは心ですけどね
それがどうにもならんですよ
だから智慧ある人はこれを育てるんですよ
文句言わない これ難しいとか言わない
だからやるんです 難しいんだから
矢を作る職人は矢を整えるようにと
昔の矢っていうのは木の枝でしたからね
木の枝はぐにゃぐにゃ曲がっちゃって矢にはなりません
あ この枝曲がってるんだから矢になりませんよ
捨てますよということはないんです
それはあらゆる過程を温めたり
泥の中に入れておいたり
もう 1ヶ月とかも泥の中に入れておいて
それからまっすぐに何かに結んでおいたりとか
いろんなことをしてまっすぐの矢を作るんです
ドゥンニッガハッサラフノーヤッタカーマニパーティーノチッタサダマトウサードゥチッタンダンタンスカワハ
心は掴みにくい すぐ逃げちゃう
まあ理解できない 好きなものにばかり執着する
心っていうのは好きなもの
好きなもの 好きなもの言っちゃうんです
その心を制御した方がよろしい
制御した心は幸福を招く
お釈迦様が言うのは 心を育てるということは
もう並大抵のことじゃないんだということ
でも頑張ってくださいと
それしか道がない すべて心は決めするんだから
難しい 難しいともう言ってるんじゃないんです
言ってる場合じゃないんです
はい 次に行きます ディソーディサンヤンタンカイラウェリーパーワーナウェリーワーパナウェリナンミッチャーパナヒタンチッタンパーピヨーナンタトーカレ
敵が相手の敵に何をするかと
まあ敵っていうのは 2種類ありますよ
私が相手は敵だと思っても
相手が私を敵だと思わない場合もありますよ
そうじゃなくて 私は相手がとんでもない敵だと
相手も私がとんでもない敵だと思っている場合は
何をするんですかね 一緒にあったところでめちゃくちゃやっちゃうでしょう
そこで憎しみのある人は
えーとなんかおかしいな
文章は 憎しみの人は自分を憎しみ
相手に何をするかと で
私は憎しみを持っていて
誰かに対して その人は私に対して憎しみを持っている場合は
お互いやっちゃうともう大変なことになりますよ
私は人を憎んでも 相手が私のことを憎んでない場合は
それほど大きな問題になりません
損害は少ない 互いに憎しみ合っていると
もう損害は切りがないんです
悪い方向へ育てた心が
それよりも酷いことを自分にするんです
心を育てていないと 心は悪い方向に行っちゃうと
自分にはもっとひどいことをするんです
なぜならば 管理者が心だから
支配者が心だから逃げられません
生きることが心ですからね
命っていうのは心ですから
それが間違っちゃうと
どうにもならないんです
ネタンマーターピターカイラアンジェーワーピチナータカーサンマパニヒタンチッタンセイヤソーティナンタトーカレという
意味は 母にも父にもしてあげることはできない
他の親戚にもしてあげることはできないほどの幸福を制御した己の心がしてくれるんです
仏教は母と父というのはもうもう最高な意味で使ってます
これには神入れたってもいいんです
神にもしてくれることができないものは
自分の心が綺麗だったらやってくれますよ
だって神様を信仰するという宗教の中でも
神には何もできんですよ
我々はちゃんと頑張らないと
結局はそういう話になるんです
だから 母が父がね 子供に対しては何でもしてあげたい気持ちはあるんだけど
リミットがあるんですよ
すごい抜群の立派な親戚がいると
なんとかしてあげたい気持ちはあるかもしれませんだけど
例えば小泉さんみたいなすごい偉い方が親戚だったらね
自分の親戚には何とかしてあげたいんだけど
やっぱりリミットがあるんですよ
だから自分の心を育てれば
リミットはなく すごい幸福をしてくれます
ということで 話は終了いたします